I want to put all joking aside for just
a second I want to talk about something
important
now that the elections are over I want
to take just a moment to reflect on what
President Obama's re-election really
means now think about it we have elected
an african-american president for a
second time and while we may not be in a
post-racial world yet the signs are
strong that we are headed in that
direction now sure there were still
barriers to break but together we've
made huge strides towards equality and I
want you to know I stand by my
african-american brothers because it is
they have to do this guy what the hell
does a guy that white know about being
black
Coenen is so white he makes MIT Romney
but like shouldn't night even worse he
thinks the N double AC P stands for
North American affluent Caucasian people
: locks his car doors when he drives by
a Tyler Perry built water talking Wonder
Bread Tory thinks Denzel Washington is a
town in the Pacific Northwest
I'm tired of Conan asking me to
introduce him to Nelson Mandela and they
died from the Old Spice commercials sure
Conan we all shoot hoops every weekend
at Maya Angelou's house all this from a
guy who thinks jungle fever is when you
eat spicy food at her rainforest cafe
God is he still talking hey my mind if I
get a piece it is Asscher idea go right
ahead
Conan so white albinos call him caca
one time Connie came up to me and said J
minus Z was his favorite rap stir the
only hood he's ever been in is the one
on his obi-wan kenobe costume do you
think Conan's gonna figure out that
black people can talk telepathically not
just black people really cool white
people too
[Applause]
you